wir versuchen unser krankes Huhn Wilma
zu retten das hat lege not deswegen habe
ich mich mit Calcium und Öl bewaffnet
bei einer lege not steckt im Huhn ein Ei
fest und deswegen haben wir der guten
Wilma hier regelmäßige warme Bilder
verordnet damit Sie sich richtig schön
entspannen kann und das Ei einfach so
aus ihr raus flutscht wo wir gerade beim
Thema flutschen sind was auch hilft bei
lege Not ist Öl in die Kloake
einzuführen natürlich mit einer Nadel
ohne Spritze einfach damit das Ei noch
leicht da rauskommen kann und dann kam
der große
Tierarzt steckt gar kein Ei in Wilma
fest sondern ihr lege Darm ist einfach
nur super entzündet und sie hat
Wasserbauch sucht der Tierarzt malt ihr
keine großen Chancen aus aber vielleicht
hat ja der eine oder andere da draußen
noch irgendeinen Tipp oder irgendwie
Erfahrung mit dieser Erkrankung und
vielleicht können wir will mal ja noch
irgendwie helfen